We set our goals in the beginning
because they will effect the rest of
the decisions we make.
For example, if our goal is related
to brand awareness, we may choose to
advertise on bill boards and the online
equivalent of bill boards, display ads.
If you goal is driving more traffic
to your website, you'll probably
focus your advertising with online
ads with clear call to action.
Like join us today and
get free membership for a year.
If your goals are very specific
to one segment or audience or
location, then you may choose some
local channels to advertise on.
It might hanging posters
in the local dog park.
Or having your online ad on
the homepage of a local popular
business in your town.
For us one of the goals we have set for
Abarkment is to increase traffic of
dogs owners to our website 5% monthly.
That means that we're going to
focus our marketing plan on
online ads that target
our niche audience.
We might also produce a funny video,
fancy dogs, and a call to action at
the end that says, receive our
promotional offer or a launch special.
And then we're just going to
hope the video goes viral and
we get even more customers.
Now, for our goal or brand awareness,
we'd probably prefer to use display
ads on dog related websites.
Or run a Facebook, Pinterest, or
a Google+ campaign inside
dog owner communities.